I have assembled the greatest con men in
the NFL do just well enough to get the
money then your talent disappears but
fitzy you've stolen millions in the Rams
bangles bills Titans Texans Jets what
else is this I'm gonna steal the
starting QB job for the Bucs here's the
plan I caused the distraction in the
media ahem I went to Harvard but I'm
wearing silly clothes next we need a QB
controversy that's where Sammy sleeves
comes in look maybe you should start the
rookie Dalton Marvin I need you to get
people excited but still lose a wild
card game Allie AFC North really up for
grabs at this point no one will know
what it takes to be an NFL quarterback
and if I play one good hand
I'll get the job now eventually I'll be
exposed uh sir you're gonna want to see
this only I get to be overpaid
get up Tannehill that's what you can
choose everybody they are three you know
uh and they'll have to start me at any
questions why don't we just play great
football all the time because that's so
hard